Leena was watching a football game the
team she was cheering for gained six
yards on one play it lost eight yards on
the next play it lost another two yards
on the following play Leena wants to
know what her team's net change in field
position was after these three plays
which of the following equations matches
the situation above so let's think about
it the team she was cheering for first
they gained six yards so that's positive
six yards then it then they lost eight
so it would be six minus eight and then
it lost another two so six minus eight
minus two this is six minus eight but
then plus two so this isn't right this
is six plus negative eight which is
equivalent to six minus 8 plus negative
two so this would be equivalent to six
minus eight minus two or another way to
think about it they gained six yards
then they lost eight yards and then they
lost another two yards so definitely go
with that one let's keep going Eddie and
Fran are scuba-diving
Eddie is 35 meters below the surface of
the water and Fran is 8 meters directly
above him the following situation
describes this or the following equation
describes this situation so let's see
Eddie is 35 meters below the surface of
the water so when we're below the
surface that we're coming or the more
below the surface we are the more
negative I guess is is what we're doing
here so if we're at the surface of the
water you would be at 0 meters and they
tell us Fran is 8 meters above him so
we're taking we're taking Eddie's depth
at 35 meters and then Fran is 8 meters
above so we're adding 8 to figure out
Fran's depth of negative 27 meters
notice this is 8 meters above Eddie's
depth so negative 27 is Fran's depth she
is 27 meters below the surface of the
water so select all that apply
Fran is 27 meters below the surface of
the water yeah that's what we just
talked about if you if you if your
if your depth is or I guess you can say
you're if you're if you're at a negative
here at negative 27 that means 27 meters
below the water if you were at positive
27 that means you're 27 meters above the
water
so that's what they're telling us frans
position relative to the surface of the
water is negative 27 meters yeah I think
that's a reasonable way to say it it's a
little bit it's a little bit more
confusing but yeah she is negative 27
meters below the surface of the water
which we just set up here so I think
that's fair enough to say that as well
let's do one more
Fred's basement is flooded the basement
floor is three point four meters below
the ground floor our that makes sense
that the basement is below the ground
three point four meters the water is 1.2
meters high the following equation
describes the situation so negative 3.4
that's that's where the floor of the
basement is it's three point four meters
below the ground floor so the ground
floor would be zero so it's three point
four meters below the ground floor so
that's the negative three point four but
then the water is 1.2 meters the top of
the the surface of the water is 1.2
meters above the floor of the basement
so this negative 2.2 is how high the
surf the top of the water is so what
does negative 2.2 tell us well the top
of the water is 2.2 meters below the
ground floor yep that's right
the water is 1.2 meters above the floor
of the basement which is negative 2.2
meters and this is all relative to the
ground floor so if the ground floor is
zero the top of the water is negative 2
point 2 which means at the top of the
water is 2.2 meters below that's what
the negative tells us below the ground
floor the water is 2.2 meters deep no
that's not right they tell us that the
water is 1.2 meters high or 1.2 meters
deep so that's not right and we're not
gonna click none of the above because we
definitely found we found an answer